hi viewer it's just you and me now i
don't know if this is recording but
um i just wanted to say to you uh yeah i
do have a horrible mark on my face i
scratched it up it's fine don't worry
about it
austin's coming back and that's when i
said to austin
no i never want to work with you again
and it's great it's magical so
it's a classical day i was telling the
audience though it's fine
yeah ah that's exciting who who uh
i heard you say a name who were you
addressing i said austin
oh good it was a joke i was doing a bit
basically i was doing a bit
i love it uh well
the show suffers when it's just us too i
think no
no i think i think we're about to turn a
corner and it's about
the high mark that has ever been
achieved
uh why don't you just tell a story
uninterrupted how about that
just tell just tell i feel like half the
comments or the videos are austin's try
to tell a story tell us a story just
like five minutes just i'm just gonna
sit back i've had a long week i'm gonna
drink my pepsi
come get some coffee tell me tell me an
anecdote about something anything
uh well i we were postulating
uh i don't i don't have an anecdote i
haven't i'm sorry have you been to the
doctor about that
is that yes yeah i've i've been told
although i love hilariously that you
jumped right in um yeah no absolutely
that's on brand it's fine
that's cool i know my role here yeah
exactly
um joining us
we're all ready we're already rolling oh
i saw that red light
all right this is gold i was coming on
immediately with
a here we are face to face
a couple of silver spoons hoping to find
we're two of a kind
ready to go ready to show
together you guys are too young
yeah i know you're really it's actually
driving me crazy because i know
he's not is that like a sesame street
thing is that like a sesame street
i don't know you americans you have your
pop culture don't you what is it
silver spoons a couple of silver spoons
that literally the titular
line in the song is it's a song
it's a theme song to to
a seminal 80s
i guess you could call it a sitcom
starring
ricky schroeder who would readily
correct you say it's rick
um i'll never forget for people who
remember ricky schroeder i love
just barreling down having no idea what
conversation i'm walking into right now
than the fact that i know you have a
haircut
you've not interrupted anything about it
you guys were talking about hitler
before and i'm like let me talk about
ricky schroeder for a second
so ricky schroeder was was like teen
heartthrob teen bop
you know he was just speaking of hitler
blonde hair blue eyed
just just ticked the boxes of all of you
know what we loved about america
oh my god this this is quite the uh this
is
equals you know apple pie baseball and
for whatever reason
this this is reflective in the casting
there's a lot of people that cast people
who were
blonde hair and blue eyed because dark
hair for some reason skewed either
european or scared something else and so
it's like for whatever reason
america represented this hair color and
this cycle it's stupid
uh anyway so guy the kid finds out um
this guy is like he's a wealthy
billionaire man child who has uh a
son and he never met him and all of a
sudden he's like hey i guess
i'm your kid uh he's like oh okay well
i've got a train in my
house and i also have video games uh if
you want to come live here and we'll
make a tv show about it
and so they did
and then aaron gray was on it she played
like the
i don't know if it was like she was the
person who was like making sure that he
wasn't beating
ricky schroeder you know what i like
about this story was that it had this
really long runway and then it was the
equivalent of like a hairier jump jet
that then just
just like it wasn't this long
acceleration it was like then there's
this and this and this and then
they made the show yeah was was that why
like this
was the hitler jump was that the one
that that you that was a framing device
that i think works what i love about
this story is i don't
know i don't recognize any of the names
you're saying
i don't know cultural context it is
entirely possible wait wait wait wait
where you've made up a show you know
aaron gray
did you never watch did you never watch
buck buck rogers
wasn't [ __ ] roaches like like in the 50s
no
buck rogers was in the uh 70s early 80s
guild gerard
yeah i've gone
i'm this is what happens when alan is
like you rarely uh you rare i mean i
don't get to you be the young guy on the
show very often so i'm gonna i was just
gonna say
that's you're rarely you're rarely like
who is the best as the clueless
millennial
uh in this lineup um of us three it's
probably i'm it's me it's now i'm 35.
alana's the youngest oh sorry alana
obviously when alana's here but
yeah mike you and i i'm i'm 36 you and i
are very close in age
um you're much wiser though you've made
good use of that extra year i think
you've it was all in that extraordinary
value of it yeah
yeah from 1984 to 85 i was like i got to
get a running start on
mr bithell so i'm glad to know it paid
off how did you know about mike
in 1984 the same way that i knew to do
anything there was a star
and uh there were three wise men three
guys showed up it was like hey
[Laughter]
three guys showed up and they were like
you've got one year make it count
um it was more of a message to my
parents but uh guys guys who's the
[ __ ] that brought murr
i was me that was the only thing they
had in the gift shop we told you
gold frankincense silver these are three
things that you bring to a baby's
birthdays like you brought
murr so i could yeah but
but that did maybe that's what set me on
my path towards music is the
is the goal of you know is going through
three special characters that i just
gaffed
no the the uh you know the anticipation
of my birth
well that too there were no angels
singing on that day
i don't think it was it was just some
guy walking around good
sean bloke got got squeezed out just a
minute ago
mike will go say hi to him he's going to
see he's going to do
this is this is from the daily mail
that's where i got it from
anyway something about the rhythm of the
chewing
i can't even pretend to have an opinion
on the telegraph i i genuinely don't
even know what they
i don't think i've ever read the
telegraph i don't know it's kind of like
it would be the outliers like usa today
it's kind of like okay
but like you're not new york times not
new york post you're not like making
these polarizing comments
this is the weirdest episode we've ever
done
let me ask you mike on the subject of
british
news because i'll take this mic
obviously
obviously the daily mail has this very
so shall we say fraught reputation
um but is it because it i i can never
i've never taken the time to kind of do
due diligence on this because sometimes
it looks like it's basically just
transparently tabloid
like no different than national inquirer
but then there are other times where
i'll see
what would appear to be very viable
articles like very
like they look like an earnest shot at
news and if you
if you came in with no baggage you would
see it no differently than any other
headline so what
what am i saying we so the key the
easiest one of the easiest way i've ever
been able to explain
to americans is essentially flip like
cable news and newspapers in your brain
like culture sorry i didn't mean to flip
you both off there um
it's like our newspapers have a lot of
kind of
are they're more centrist more generally
that's something sorry about
our news channels sorry are more
centrists kind of riddle middle of the
road
you know both sides kind of arguments
that's actually shifting there is an
attempt to kind of start the british fox
news at the moment happening but like
generally
our politics is are more the more um
uh the stronger ends of the spectrum are
represented in newspapers and you have
yeah tablet
tabloids sheets daily mail's an
interesting case
because what happened with the daily
mail was it was always
definitely right leaning um well sorry
extremely like on the right of british
politics
what's interesting is it's one of the
few british
papers or i guess any paper
internationally that
did incredibly well on the internet and
kind of got
like like became just this massive
international online brand
that's the only reason that's what
you're experiencing is you're seeing
like a right-wing paper that is all
right you guys had a twitter
should we take it let's take our
articles to twitter should we do oh i'll
get all right on it
you're watching you're watching like
what if like a
right wing newspaper like went full tilt
like online tabloid and that's that that
the the kind of the discrepancy you're
talking about is those two sides of the
same company i know it's it's hands it's
hands it's directing i'm directing the
conversation
conductors
but yeah no it's it's that you're saying
that's what you're that that that
dichotomy you're seeing there is
kind of what the impression i get
is there anybody uh
outside like is there anybody that would
i guess what i would i'm trying to suss
out is if they have any redeeming
sort of journalistic uh quality because
i
i will see things every now and again
just on facebook or whatever ambiently
someone will share something
and it will look like a totally normal
piece of news and then only will i
when i realize where it's coming from
will i re well i think
like i wouldn't have known and that's
why it's curious because
that's why i'm sure there are
journalists there who i'm sure there are
journalists there who kind of follow a
new story where it takes them et cetera
i don't agree with them politically on
anything but that's the thing
i'm sure there's a there's a in the same
ways there's like it looks like from the
outside
you're making me so self-conscious
um but like i i my son from my
what i can see from what i see of clips
of like fox news is you have like
the opinion stuff which goes wildly
off-piste and then it seems like there
are like
right-wing news hosts who are still
again like yeah there was a shepherd
nonsense but like they have like it's
what is it that's the truthiness the
stephen colbert thing of like it feels a
bit
like it's you know truth or jason it has
the veneer of real news kind of thing i
think that's the same thing this is why
i asked because
tablet definitely by the way i'm
definitely like a very biased source of
information about all this because i'm
super lefty as you both know no well i i
think it's all trash anyway
that well that's why i was curious
because um like there's a distinct
difference between
what like fox is a good is a good
comparison from the standpoint that
that what makes them their money are the
people that are unabashedly
not they're not even pretending to say
this is what this is our stab at
objectivity it's people saying
this is very much my view that's your
that's your tucker carlson's your sean
hannities et cetera and then their
during the day lineup
is this we we purport to be uh
you know more theoretically still with
the angle and the lean
towards the right undoubtedly but they
but they do claim some
some semblance of journalism with their
actual journalists and
whereas like tabloid to me is like tmz
it's just it's not even it's not even in
the same universe that we're talking
about because when i saw the daily mail
it it looked a lot closer to tmz
that's what that's what formed my
opinion which is why i was like
is it is it this is it a chimera of
like national inquirers alien landing
and yeah okay that that is the british
tabloid press
does that like and because i think there
was definitely the thing historically in
the uk
where if you you know you have your
newspaper subscription and
and and you know those those tablets
kind of use the sensationalist kind of
stuff as like it was like
it's like having the funny pages in the
paper like i was like yes you'd have
your
you'd have you're more kind of like big
journalism and then you'd have like your
yeah it's it's it's all leaning in the
same direction it's all giving you the
same message but there's definitely like
the
you know the the the fun stuff which is
a bit more extreme
it sounds it sounds similar to the way
fox is packaged yeah yeah
well except that on fox you don't see
the like
photos revealed of loch ness monster in
lost
camper bag of you know like there's less
of that on the mail
like i think there's less of that
there's definitely less of that in like
the paper i think like i think that's
more of the online side that's they're
definitely
they're good at getting the clicks like
that's always that's definitely like the
thing that stands out like if you look
at like which
british papers have like an
international thing it really is
basically the mail and the guardian
right and i think the guardian's image
internationally is much more kind of
like wall street journal they're they're
they're seen as yeah they're seen as
like a
establishment left-leaning real
good german journalism kind of thing
yeah so it's a different
different two different parts i'm sure
the daily mail making more money with uh
tabloid bullshits and your things you
know
that's the thing that's always
astonishing is like the the ratings
comparisons between msnbc and fox are
are so lopsided it's insane like which
way does it lean like oh fox calls
fox crushes oh like and msnbc is that's
your like
that's your left of center american
music they're the counter yeah they're
the they're the antidote to fox news or
the
the the you know the the the offset i i
guess you could think of it but they're
from the other audience as a fraction of
the size
i mean definitely american politics
excuse to the right like anyway just
generally but it does seem
msnbc isn't as far left as fox's far
right right like it's and i'm not using
far right to its extreme
but like it seems it does seem like it's
msnbc is closer to the center into the
reality than
boxes that's probably true it might be
splitting hairs a little bit but i think
that's
probably true um uh but
like i said i'm from the outside like
and like you know
in the thing that i always have to point
out to like american friends is like
obama would have been
a tory in this country like from its
policies like obama would be on the
right of british politics
like certainly biden at least biden
up up till the point of like in the
primaries you know he
he's actually been he's actually been
more left
than you would have guessed from the
outside prior to his election in terms
of the actual policies he's pursuing
but he yeah biden was always very much a
center-left
type that that by british comparison
would be
yeah he'd be kind of center to maybe
even slightly right yeah just exactly
because again that overton window is
different in every country in the world
right like that's that's the fascinating
aspect of it
yeah absolutely and the fact that also
the thing that always drives me crazy is
the
the kind of arbitrariness with which
terms like liberal
uh are are thrown around and they mean
they mean wildly
different things in different countries
yeah all right next question
uh true this is gonna be for me that
seems oh good okay cool
no well it's this is this is inspired by
you right before you arrive very
organized this i like it it's good
turns out alana was the source of chaos
although has been messing this whole
thing up
this is this is now a professional
podcast uh maybe when she shows up i
just won't let her in
um but uh so
questioned as our as the resident expert
on parenthood
total total left turn here um
we were talking about when young infants
yes mike mike is showing off his war
wound
with you buddy apparently carrie has
educated him as mainly an infant thing
because i scratched my face in the night
and i've been told that that's a thing
babies do
is that right yeah but i mean i can go
off on that but
okay well here was my question you're on
the right show let's go off on that
let's
don't don't don't prevent them from
doing that keep looking okay that was
that okay interesting that was gonna be
kind of where i go with it because i
remember the first time
that i ever knew that was a phenomenon
was i met a friend who had a young like
one-year-old or
six month old that had little cotton
balls on their fingertips and i was like
what
weird gecko am i looking at i mean it
was the most because i couldn't tell
what i was looking at as i walked up to
him and he said dude
my kid is like wolverine and he
basically gouges his eyes out at night
and i never knew that was a thing so he
doesn't gouge his eyes out
there's no way that was the thing my
question straight straight to
evolutionary biology of well wait a
minute though
we might be blind yeah or we would never
have developed eyes or something you
know we would have
we would have regressed into photos
there's a lot of there's a lot of uh
future man there's something in the
water right now there's a lot of
quarantine babies a lot of coveted
babies that are popping out right now
or will be very soon uh and i have a i
have
virtually no unsolicited opinions i have
some notions and some things that i
would i would call
encouragement but i have no opinion all
right i have a lot of opinion but i have
no uh uh advice
yeah everybody is there to it's your i
know i don't you don't know your baby
how can i tell you how to raise your
baby you have no idea
uh and i don't believe that there's a
pat way that you should just this is how
you raise a child
i do believe that there are some uh
great
bumper rails that you can put in place
but one of the best pieces of
the best notion that someone floated to
me that has served me well
was that if it has a barcode it's for
the parent not the baby
that's fair if it has a barcode it's for
your
benefit not for the babies so because
pretty much especially for the first
they call it the fourth trimester so
gestation period is nine months
the three months that follow when the
baby is born
i'll never forget this uh traveler when
he first came out
um was there there were a couple things
that were concerning and we brought in
our one pediatrician he didn't register
any flags but he was an [ __ ] we fired
him we brought in his current
pediatrician
who was amazing and after looking at him
he while he was holding him
um we were like well we were concerned
about this we were concerned about this
and this that he goes guys
give him a second he just went through
like it's
the most traumatic thing that we will
ever go through he's basically in exile
right now from his home
yeah the most the most traumatic thing
and i i love this as a comparison the
most traumatic thing that you've ever
experienced
ever ever the most violent traumatic
thing you've ever experienced
you experienced as a child when you were
the most vulnerable
the most susceptible to disease or
anything and you made it
you made it through so that's
encouragement you can get through
traffic you can get through losing your
job you can get through that breakup you
can get through anything because you did
that hardest thing job done um
so i i firmly believe like i've got a
nana which is a
great baby monitor device that
has a barcode on it that is 100 for us
it doesn't help travelers sleep any
better
but it helps me feel better um the
the the whole thing about babies are
able to move when they're in the womb
that's what the kicks come from and
they're swimming and they're flipping
doing everything else
the whole thing of get them out and bind
them
there's studies that have shown that
people have
that that leads to adult things that
they have to unpack later
um so the whole thing about scratching
your eyes you you're
you're determining object permanence and
situational awareness
because of that it's like i st yeah i
the other day yesterday as a matter of
fact i was moving something and i
i hit traveler in the head and he just
looked at me i was like
dude uh let me walk you through a
traveler always wants to know what
happened he's like can i tell you what
when he falls down can i tell you what
happened yeah so you
you were running really fast this way
and there's the the curb is uneven and
so you
you stepped on that and you fell and you
hit yourself right here can you feel
that yeah okay how does it feel now
so we talk them through everything so
the the
the whole notion of well i want to i
want to it hurts a a parent to see their
child in flick pain
anytime you see blood on your child i it
there is something literally instinctual
that happens within me so i understand
the parent of going i have to keep
his hands or or her hands covered or
else they will hurt themselves
yeah do you know how long it takes for a
baby to heal
holy [ __ ] they're like wolverine it's
insane i guess they're wolverine on both
aspects of that then there's like
the death claws
yeah so i mean the other thing is like
keep them trimmed
we but we've we've cut travelers nails
since he was you know
a couple months old so let me ask you he
cuts or whatever and it's like oh yeah i
got a good cut right there he's not
going to cut his eye out
the what eyelids are for the one uh
when you i like this idea
uh well i don't know i'm curious
to unpack this idea of if it has a bar
code
it's for the parent that's an
interesting delineation um
where is this agent 47
no no he's just for the penalty not for
the baby he's just the parents
yeah got it maybe come for the baby
[Laughter]
assad is the opposite he's there he's
he's there too he's there to take out
the parents
yeah exactly um so is
does that mean that there is a
contingent of parents that i've never
known about
that that like because diapers would be
a very obvious
that's a bar-coded item yeah that
obviously
so then what what would a what is the
literal without
devolving into something horrible what
is the
uh is there like a a sort of
yeah like i was gonna say what is the
solution to
is there like a paleo parenting uh
you know subgroup that i don't know
about
like full on to the extreme like no
electricity
100 and there's books written about them
which have a barcode which is for the
parents
um word of mouth only should be the way
that there's that community it's written
on a leaf
it's written on the leaflet no no
there's some people not even written a
card
um there are some people that go hard
they go den you know and they're like
i'm i'm mama bear and these are my cubs
um
there's a lot there's a lot of studies
that show you know nowhere else in
nature
does an animal put their child you know
50 feet away from them and then they go
sleep in a separate cave
they always sleep together until finally
that that animal goes i'm out and they
leave
and i was avidly against i was like
day one that kid's in a crib are you
kidding me i want my bed back
i had this [ __ ] next to me for the last
nine months complaining and i'm taking
over pillows it was great man
pam i didn't see her for the last like
trimester because she just had this
wall of pillows i was like i'm assuming
you're there and haven't rolled over
good night
um and i was excited to get my bed back
and we started talking about
tyler come to sleep with us i was like
no it's like why and i asked my
pediatrician this is like
why why are you opposed to that i was
like uh because i move when i sleep he's
like oh my god i'm so sorry i didn't
realize that
how often do you fall out of bed and i
went right yeah
what because how often do you fall in
bed it's like never fall a vegas isn't
that amazing when you're asleep you
still can judge
the edge of the bed and i i may have
shared this story before
i was asleep yeah everyone's nodding i
only moved my hand
pam caught my hand over traveler's face
dead asleep never woke up
there is some crazy ass [ __ ] that
happens when a woman becomes a mom it's
just
insane there's some things that have
happened to me too there's just
instinctual things that start coming
alive that were
systems that were not online but the the
notion of
you know sleep with this and the
traveler when he was like nine months
old was like i'm out i don't want to
sleep in here anymore and he got his own
room
slept at night never had a problem it's
great so i i think that there's some
times which is like
and i i really feel like the way that we
were raised as kids we're now seeing the
effects of that as
adults where it's like we need to have
discussions we need to talk out our
feelings we've kind of suppressed these
things and now it's kind of like i don't
know which way it's supposed to feel or
this way or this way
so i'm all about raising the humid he's
going to be a kid for a blip
but he's going to be a human and an
adult for the rest of his life and so
i'm trying to teach him right now i say
things to him right now is like
hey man i need to uh if you do this
then i can do this for you because
you'll prove to me that this is really
important to you your dad did the same
thing with you austin it's like if the
consequence is worth the action go for
it but you will pay the consequence
i love that that's the way that we
parents like dude if you want to do that
totally fine that means that this and
when that thing happens and he goes no i
don't want that like i have to be a man
of my word
i have to be a man of my word and i want
you to be a man of your word
and so when he does stuff and he goes i
was a man of my word i'm like
you understand that from from a literal
syntax standpoint right now
but there is a seed of the conceit and
the seed of the concept
that has taken root and i want that [ __ ]
to grow so that's that's all that i care
about right now
[ __ ] i love him he's so [ __ ] rad the
kid is awesome
it's the best i didn't want to be a dad
didn't want to be a parent
had no desire i was out nope
the second that pam said we're praying
was like try to take that kid from me
and every dude these laughs
just to be clear no i told her we're
pregnant it was weird
she was like what was like your parents
just had a sense you just had a feeling
right
now these things the mini chlorine
strong with you yeah oh yeah anyway
i'll go off i i will i will easily rant
and rave
uh because it's it's really i'm excited
for greg and it's been
very hard for me greg miller it's been
very hard for me to just reach out to
greg
and go learn from my mistakes but i'm
like that's the whole point of being a
dad
is you've got to learn it's like learn
and and
mistakes just to be clear that is the
point of being a dad
that is the point of being a dad making
mistakes this is why i guess i'm
grateful that i'm the younger sibling
uh is that uh i guess the trial run
happened in the older siblings protested
yeah
i would be i would really be really
curious to see like my parents
my sister and i as growing up was very
very different and and we still unpack
difference again
two and a half years so not too
dissimilar see we're five
i thought it was like three or four so
it's five years different what about you
mike
five uh to my my little sister yeah it's
uh
three four years yeah i thought you're
the youngest i'm the oldest
you're the only three little sisters
yeah all right
you think they'd stop after you no
one had no idea they had no idea how bad
it was going to get though it was
uh i have a friend this is this is this
is the thinnest of tangents but
i have a friend who is in his mid-30s
who met his birth parent his birth
mother for the first time
uh this week he he grew up adopted and
uh and thanks to what's it like what's
it called one of the
like ancestors 23 and me was that one
yeah he was able to
really like just like the did the thing
and it said
it's a whole it's a by the way you're
two percent mongolian and here's your
birth mother
that's amazing kind of yeah he tried it
years ago
and he was starting to feel that um
he was starting to feel this sort of
down like she's you know
based on a pro like based on what little
information he knew he was like
i don't know how much longer it would be
reasonable to just assume
fairly she's alive and so he was
starting to feel like he was running out
of time so he did it again
without thinking about the idea that the
database would have grown considerably
since he did it last and it led to this
whole crazy story of discovering that he
has a half brother
where the half brother was raised as
like this total cliche new york italian
uh and uh sorry excuse me sorry austin
troy could you quickly
do that voice for us yeah total cliche
no i'm only 26 years old that's the
thing
i was definitely hearing far more of
like a de niro but
but uh this is definitely the
grandfather of the orc
now it's today right now it's getting
the tadeero head dog yeah
like he's fighting an infection draw it
again it's a simple diagram draw it
again
yeah that exists in hereford
apparently this guy so he was just like
it was drilled into him
massively as a kid because it turned out
that um that uh it was like
it's this whole i'm forgetting the story
but it was this whole crazy like
uh kid born uh like
basically can i think conceived at
woodstock
with like a a vietnam vet on shore leave
and like and it was everything was
insane and this guy
and there was all this shame uh that the
family was trying to hide so it was like
you're italian
you're definitely italian and like
growing up and and and then uh
then the guy grows up and he's got the
slick back hair and he's like a salesman
now
and all this stuff and then you know
his now he's like he's too yeah exactly
see no but you know what i mean like
it's it's he hams up the identity as
part of the act as it were
i've seen glee i know what it's supposed
to be
100 so then apparently what happened is
the guy goes
and uh has now got uh like teenage
daughters who want to try
23 and me and that comes back that
they're like nearly pure
german and he's like that's impossible
he does it on himself
german and he's like what the hell and
he goes to like a family reunion and
goes
who here knows if i'm adopted 20 people
in the room
all looked down at the floor in shame
all of them knew and kept the secret
kept the secret yeah he did not know
he had no idea so he's like you all have
some ant some questions to answer
finally
finds out that this woman had basically
had sex with a random guy at
woodstock given up the kid to an italian
family that
that was having a hard time uh having a
kid of their own and was like
feeling this social pressure uh and so
he uh he discovers through the process
that he has a mysterious half-brother so
meanwhile my friend who is that
half-brother
is going through his own version finds
this guy on facebook messages him and
goes it's about time i've been looking
for you for a while
and then he gets to he gets to meet his
uh he gets to meet his presence
he's literally in new york meeting her
this weekend
and the crazy thing is the beautiful
part of the story he wrote her an email
and he read it to me and it was
hilarious because it was like hey
i believe you got knocked up in
woodstock
[Laughter]
my friend sent what the hell just
happened
i i was still recording i did a terrible
new york house
broke the recording well no i just got a
weird error okay good we're all good
um so my friend sends this message it
was really sweet though because it was
like he had no idea what to say
to like what do you say to someone that
i don't know what to say
i gotta go to disneyland go to the city
to five minutes september
it's a good story man that's i was gonna
say i i'm i'm
sorry like you sold me on the pitch uh i
i'm trying
to get it yeah i'm gonna be this guy
i'm gonna play this is the trick i'm
gonna play the son
and the mother gunther spignarli that's
whatever the character that's the family
guy bit
you captured me perfectly jimmy or
whatever
i can't wait i'm gonna be i'm gonna do a
scene with myself
i'm gonna be the murderer and i'm gonna
be the son it's gonna be brilliant
and oh god now i'm doing pacino for no
reason
oh have i ever told you my pacino story
no but i wanna hear it right now
i was i was in there oh my gonna tell a
story about apache
choir okay so i was in l.a i was doing
uh i was doing john wick
and there's a vegan restaurant which is
a recent day in case it's a place the
guy loves
and he's in a vegan in l.a oh i was in
l.a
it's an amazing vegan restaurant uh that
i've been to a few times now
and me and me and my producer ben uh you
both know we're
enjoying dinner and ben's lovely he's
great um we were enjoying dinner
and i noticed about and i've got my back
to the room i know it's about like you
know at the at the starter stage
ben's face is just frozen like in
like all he has to reset his camera so
of course i do the immediate thing
i do the immediate exactly i do the
immediate thing where i
very obviously turn around and look
right and yeah the table behind us
is um is al pacino family and friends
what are the specials in there well he's
talking very quietly he's clearly trying
to keep a low profile but ben
you know ben's a massive movie fan he's
he's
overwhelmed by it i'm i'm i'm equally
like yeah obviously
super amazed by it and we don't know
we're enjoying it
and it becomes apparent as the evening
goes on
you know mr pacino and his family are
enjoying a birthday celebration for him
and they you know friends and family and
like and it's it's clearly it's not a
hollywood party it's just like you know
15 people around the table enjoying a
nice meal together and there's
little speeches but again like very
muted trying to keep like
you know not trying to draw the room in
and uh
that's what i think that's a little
birthday hey drive me back in
it's lovely it's it's just it's a nice
nice little family get together and
obviously everyone's being very
respectful in that way that obviously
everyone
in l.a is and new york and london are
very we're all very good at no single
celebrity being excited about it and
then you know moving on with our day
but then um but ben can't stop like
looking and to be honest i'm looking a
little bit as well because it's it's
[ __ ] al pacino you know that's
amazing
um and it goes on
he's like it was like a ritual i would
watch that to be honest with you
themed birthday party and i'm not making
this up and it's
and it's ensured i will forever love and
respect al pacino
end of the meal and it's his birthday i
think we looked it up on the cab ride
home like it was his birthday he was
like he was
he's definitely like in he's like in his
late 70s earlier 70 years
he's 81 now 81. are you one now
and he stands up gets up very carefully
at the end of the meal um with like you
know i i assume like you know a daughter
or granddaughter
kind of giggling at the table because
she's clearly seen this happen before
and he says i can't do an impression so
i won't drive i'll let troy do it after
he says i've noticed you all have seen
me in the room
and i just want to give you a gift to
celebrate my birthday
and then sits down i did i just was like
i thought he was gonna go tracy tracy
tracy
and he just edited he belted who are the
entire obviously the entire room sings
happy birthday to him and it was like it
was lovely it was very sweet
a friend of mine was uh was a i think at
that point he was probably a pa
for the remember the movie the the
second movie that pacino and de niro did
not heat
uh right we we just needed one what was
it called righteous kill
sure it's like we just needed heat and
we didn't need
the other one we need a michael mann to
do his and done sure
um but he said they were shooting in
in new york and so it was you know
transpo would be taking them to set or
whatever and de niro
always goes he's like has his personal
has been with him like
for forever and de niro is super demure
stays very quiet
but chino is like i want the he likes
the attention he likes
you know so he gets out he's like i'm
gonna walk
so he gets out of the van and walks in
the middle of manhattan like midtown
to set and of course it's just and
pas are going [ __ ] i was trying to keep
this guy safe
getting him to set but it was kind of
like it's probably done
a million times yeah it's the difference
between you know the two of them
and i don't fault either one one one guy
you know de niro was apparently very
quiet very private
uh and pacino's like look it is
he is just a fascinating iconic
he's incredible like both of them in
their own right are
are and you watch it's almost like
mickey rourke
when you watch nine and a half weeks
with mickey rourke there's no way that
that's the same guy from the wrestler
there's just
no way that that i was talking to him
about this was like he was a teen
heartthrob
not teen but he was like you know the
age was like how was he is like look at
him and then he decided to go be a boxer
for a second
and then that messed up his face and
he's actually this brilliant actor
that always just kind of gets cast in
these weird things but but like
you look at pacino right out of the gate
man
i mean godfather dog day afternoon
serpico
it's insane what he was able to do
in just a short amount of time it's like
my god
what's the other one uh i'm missing one
of the big ones
well you didn't say you didn't say oh
early you mean
earlier yeah devil's advocate with
kearney reeves um i was gonna he's like
duncan that's commercial cabin i was
gonna say um
son of a woman since you went there with
it but that's definitely not but that's
80s
i'm talking like 70s just right out of
the gate it was
godfather dog day afternoon serpico and
there's one more
that i'm forgetting um tell you
serpaco is the beer scarface he's
scarface
that's 80 though right 1980. actually
right 83.
83. he was in a movie called me
natalie in 1969. he played natalie
yeah he played antonio it was uh two
roles yeah
yeah it was it was crazy um
here's a movie i don't know anything
about that he did apparently after the
godfather
scarecrow do you know anything about
this film
it's like joker right but with gene
hackman
the hack man dude happy a good film
you know what i those two in it and
we've not heard of it that's that's not
a good film
yeah exactly must not aged well uh
you so your your story your your
restaurant story reminds me of a funny
experience once not that long ago
actually it was would have been
just i think a little bit before covet
where um um
the parenting cappuccino by the way this
is what this i'm already feeling this is
what it's gonna be
titled where the hell is alana
um the um i'm sorry i worry about her
i'll be honest we'll see
yeah she sent a message that she was
like i don't know what's gonna happen
my my my my pitch was that she show up
at the last five seconds and intro the
show and then be out
but we've all other than you austin
we've now
all missed an episode right i'm the
i'm the i'm the one i'm the commander
wharf of this operation
uh i was gonna i was trying to think
which next generation
then who am i definitely tasha y'all
please don't tell me i'm riker
handsome but also just a little austin's
possibly also riker because of the beard
growth midway through the show
i don't mind that i will i will i will
change how i sit in chairs
from now on who would you know why he
does that do you know why he does that
they're coming over the chair because
he's huge he's six four
six five he has he has he has a massive
back injury
and now when you watch next generation
you'll notice every single scene he's
leaning on something
he's propped up on something like he's
always having to kind of adjust he
it's really uncomfortable for jonathan
frakes to like stand up for
long periods of time i know that so
he's that's why he's always got his foot
up on a chair he's always like doing
something
what felt like weird 80s power plays are
just a guy
you know dealing with an injury trying
yeah dealing with the injury
i adore that guy so much and it is one
of my
bucket list items to be able to sit
because he directed
a couple of star trek movies that
goldsmith scored
and it is it is so my i've never had the
chance to pick the brain of a director
who directed goldsmith i've always
wanted to do that
and he's one of those guys that it takes
multiple boxes at once to be able to
have that chat with him
if you ever get the opportunity to meet
frank's you have to tell me like 24
hours i will be on the plane
i
wait wait tell it in one second wait
because i related
i didn't do a restaurant i never i never
um
spiner in a diner once which brings me
great joy because it rhymes
they might be giant lyrics was that
spider-man a diner and it brings me so
much joy
go ahead the the remember uh the
reading rainbow kickstarter it was like
massive record breaking
i threw a stack of money at it as a as a
simultaneous fan of reading rainbow and
lavar burton
and respectful just like yeah i was like
well i i i was one of the rain [ __ ] i
wanted that to exist you know and so
normally when i give to kickstarters
after the first time when you realize
how much spam you're gonna get as a
result you
you tend to just at least for me i just
give with no reward because it's usually
a friend of mine at this point where i'm
like
i'm happy to support you i don't want
your [ __ ] though and also as someone who
has put on kickstarters
it really helps your margins to like
have a few of these
rewards yeah exactly people not like
using your bandwidth as much as like it
it helps
uh with your fulfillment bandwidth so
but this was one of those instances
where it was like
for 500 bucks you can have a phone call
with levar burton and i was like
i think i have to do it so i i almost
didn't know about that i would have done
it
so so sure enough so sure enough i was
scheduled for like
here's your 10 minute window on this
time and you better not miss it because
we because they had over 100 000 backers
like they they they broke the record for
most number of people to back a single
campaign
so he had to make like 50 000 phone
calls or something insane yeah but don't
take it enough to take my word for it
okay thank you but you don't take my
word for it okay
thank you yeah exactly no so he goes
so he so we get on the phone and i was
like
look man i just i want you to know that
yes i your body of work is astounding
you're you
i have tremendous admiration but where
i'm coming from is that i'm a composer
and anyone who's ever had the
opportunity to be in something that was
set to music
by the great master jerry goldsmith is
just a chance i
i can never i can never miss and i just
think that's so special is my old
my all time hero and i said funny enough
i even have a portrait of him on my wall
and without skipping a beat lavar
burton goes in your portrait does he
have the ponytail or not
and i was like [ __ ] the fact that you
would even know to ask that question
brings me so much happiness right now
and he was like
i can honestly say no one has brought up
jerry goldsmith in these calls and
he had he had so much level of nerd is
something i've yet to encounter in this
reality
it was so cool though to hear his his
respect for him though it was
it was uh it was awesome okay troy what
was yours
oh dude phrase was awesome we did we did
young justice together
and uh he was in the room and i've met
everybody from the deck of the
enterprise with the exception
of both uh patrick doing
deforest kelly and uh patrick stewart is
that that's the
the james do what you mean yeah there's
20 comments
yeah sorry sorry sorry sorry right
you're fine you're fine james doing yeah
patrick
so patrick stewart james doing and and
deforest kelly
forest kelly were you well they're going
to be
one of those now right yeah yeah yeah
yeah so then i wasn't able to be you
know
deforest kelly died like in the 70s i
think yeah like well no
no no no he was in movies oh yeah of
course he was
and then yeah i think only a couple
years later he passed away he died after
three right no because he was in four
isn't he in the
pilot of stars he's in the next
generation yeah he's in he's in far
point
um this is this we have been on a
journey on this school i love it
oh so there we go there's our third one
after that and then
also in next gen actually and then
passed again quite soon his his
next gen episode is one of the best of
that show the scene where they share a
drink on the holodeck of the original
enterprise
well my favorite line is he says you
know by every measure your enterprise is
superior to mine but with mine i could
tell how fast we were going by the
vibration of the deck plates
and i thought that what a beautiful line
little moment that is and i love they
had to use the fan's
rebuild of that set for that scene
that's that's like a that's like a fan
built set that they use
it's lovely that's fun i didn't anyway i
didn't remember your frank's story troy
oh i just i i just went to galaxy
questions like they built a set
um
uh so anyway uh he walks in and and
we're kind of taking a break or whatever
and i was like hey man um
great work so far i i'm i'm troy is like
a nice speech i was like i'm sorry
sorry to do this junior's like here it
goes
you know and i was like i
i [ __ ] loved you in gargoyles and he
goes zenatos
and he was just down to talk about it
he's like why do you think i'm here
today he was like these guys keep hiring
me
and because of course of course you know
same people that did um uh
gargoyles did young justice and for
someone you
it's the same thing it's like i i don't
expect you to know that
the thing that i love you for this thing
is great and that thing is great but
it's like really this thing
that i really like you and kai lang
you're a dazzle
your joke is better though i was to do
like bruce
launching and launching on monday right
yeah
yeah i'm trying to finish all my work
for the year uh by monday i guess so
that i can
i've got are you is there a part of you
that that doesn't want that just needs
to stay here or you really like let's
[ __ ] go
let's let's i won't play it i won't i
genuinely won't be playing it just for
that reason because i
i think mass effect's probably better in
my memory than if i were to go back to
it now i didn't have
a lot of things though right i don't
think that's the case for me because
i've replayed them so many times
that i know that i have to have up to
date oh yeah
i think i've done four runs through that
trilogy
there's it's got to be i i wasn't when i
got my first shot i i was
i was like i don't feel or the second
day after i was kind of feeling weird
and so i broke
out my my little emulator that has my uh
like 5 000 games on it or whatever
and so i i was like what do i feel like
playing for some reason
i guess i had like a sick day and and i
i got to play nintendo and so that just
like
brings me back to kind of how i felt and
so i didn't i didn't want to play
anything and traveler was like sitting
right next to me so i couldn't go in my
room and like fire the ps5 or whatever
it
was
um and so we're just sitting on the
couch and i was like i'm going to play
this he's like i want to see and so i
fired up chrystallis
i was like this is a game that no matter
what i'll i'll play it right now it's
like
it's a weird one but it's it's like the
first
i don't know it's like i have this i
have this weird it's not the first game
that i ever played
by far but it's it's definitely one that
just like i don't know
it's one of my go-to's but there are
very few games that i've
i will replay multiple times um
that's why i do like games that have
replayability but not necessarily i want
to go back through and play the campaign
it's just stuff that i want to go back
in and drop in it's like continue to
play rather than replay right you want
to yeah i'm keeping
i'm look you know i i am the 100 like
not episodic necessarily but as far as
like you know
open world ftp like that i'm i'm that
candidate like give me stuff that i can
just kind of continually drop in and
and buy new worlds buy new gadgets and
[ __ ] that's
i'm your i'm your sucker 100 that's why
i avoid those
like i remember basically exactly
everquest
everquest uh was a was an enlightening
experience for me as a young man because
i realized
my predilection for genuine like
non-functional addiction to this
is legit like i
i will rearrange my schedule in order to
maximize
my time in this world and so by the time
i broke free of it was right about the
time that world of warcraft was coming
out and i was like thank god there
before the grace of god goes austin that
beer would have been real long
oh for sure i don't i don't like to
finish things
i don't like i do and if they have no
ending
then i'm trapped for eternity i'm like
i'm like doctor strange in the
dormammu loop like i i i just can't get
out
that's that i i want that i i don't
seeing credits necessarily doesn't it's
like that's it i'll never have that
again
so to me to be able to perpetually stay
in there is uh
isn't that beautiful look
you're the king of like reckoning we're
gonna talk about death again yeah yeah
yeah you're it's what makes life
beautiful is that it has an end
yeah exactly i remember
what happens when journey starts to roll
credits is before it says a single
credit name it says thank you for
playing and i remember getting
tweets from people saying i don't
remember ever being thanked by the game
before
uh and uh and it was like
that to me i i don't know if they i
i'm surely they didn't do that for the
first time but just that idea of like
and now we move on i i don't know to me
that's actually vastly more
um uh appealing
than it being more like
the the bar you go to every friday to
hang out with your friends or something
you know i i don't know
it's like that feeling of i remember a
good a good comparison might be i
remember
um finishing reading return of the king
on a plane
and it was a very powerful experience to
just close that lap
close the back cover and then just look
out the window at [ __ ]
middle earth it felt like it felt like
that's what it looked like from that
perspective
it was such a moving experience to say
goodbye you know it's like they're
literally
sailing off to the you know into the
west uh
to but what the hell is it called and
blanking my nerd cred is shattering
before us um westeros come on
i started saying valinor it's not that's
not it
sorry my bad apologies this is all gonna
have to get cut for the sake of our
reputation
i honestly can't remember uh i've had
that situation literally
on the plane before too is either
finishing a show because
i just would plow through whatever show
and and it's like
okay that was it i did a man a man on
the high castle i finished i was like
okay
that one i was like i'm glad to be done
with it this needed to end you know
where it where it did it was great i was
like a little long in the tooth
um i never understood that show cause
i've not i've not watched i've read the
book
the book ends at a point where i think
valentine's day they got to in the first
three or four episodes
they kept extrapolating just so we're
all clear
valinor no no no no
um what did i say what i don't know
i got a plan that's still playing that
he's going hard like that they
dig it i don't know wait wait don't ruin
it we almost went the whole show without
talking about video games
i wasn't talking i was talking about you
know he goes and plays a valheim
football team
oh good it's the icelandic football team
they play play with the football they
play
really hard stones this is a snowball
it gets bigger as the game goes on which
makes it more and more challenging but
they can only play in the winter and
then
you know it's like just wet um
why don't austin since you're our host
why don't you do the honors
it feels so wrong i i i was giving a
lana this like
you have your shot i guess she's going
to record an intro so we we can just
we can just say nothing my hope is that
she does no that's not right that's not
right that's not right we
she should she'll do her own intro but
you should also do one you've
you've stepped in yeah you've separated
this all right all right i've shepherded
this entire
situation this is an honor that you
deserve to enjoy it
well we're gonna this is a coup we will
we won't interrupt you though that's the
important thing like
yeah i'll never be able to master the
alana like
like looking at the like the gym
you know john krasinski thing that she
does whenever we misbehave
um oh
brutal all right well in that case hello
this is play watch listen i'm here
austin austin
hi everybody [ __ ] sorry everyone yeah
just hi
everybody just just it's not a problem
just we just want to get it for coverage
we'll probably not use it we'll we'll go
with your ad-lib that's that was very
funny but can we wait
it's mirrored on mine that is mike
bithell
that is troy baker
that is austin wintery there were no job
titles this time
troy you're just you're just like having
severe like
break out the side of the yeah yeah your
neural pathways are not firing correctly
uh see you later
yeah alana doesn't exist
the mystery continues magic and that's
that
oh wait one more thing